and what's doing the perceiving well
that's the self you know the self is
somewhere between behind the eyes in the
skull in the body somewhere the self is
that which does the perceiving and
another way to think about it is that
know the self itself is a perception
what we see here is an experiment that
shows how something we take for granted
which is what is our body
so normally normally I said don't try
this at home but seriously try this at
home
it's it's lots of fun so what's
happening here is somebody you have this
sir it's called the rubber hand illusion
and there's that there is a fake hand
there the the guy in the blue t-shirt
can see it his real hand is hidden out
of sight so he's looking at this fake
hand the experiment has strokes both
hands in synchrony and so what's
happening the guy is looking at the fake
hand he's seeing something that looks
like a hand and is roughly where her
hand should be he's feeling touch on
that hat because his real hand is being
stroked that's enough evidence in this
sort of Bayesian way for the brain to
make a best guess mm-hmm but that fake
hand is part of his body now it doesn't
feel exactly like its hand in fact it a
lot of individual differences in that
that depend on various things but it's
it's an uncanny feeling and you can tell
what the brain is really assimilating
that because when you stab the fake hand
you get this as you could see quite a
dramatic a startle response and you know
this is something we'd like to do at
science festivals the children will have
like you know full-body versions of this
way you can where you can have kids stab
mannequins in the stomach and we're not
gonna do that the point underlying it is
is that yes we tend to assume that yeah
this is my body in the rest of the world
it is something else
you
[Music]